you know at madison square garden guys
in addition to
jerseys in the rafters for players who
have played for the rangers the knicks
uh they have some other legends in the
building there's a billy joel
banner for all the sold out concerts
that billy has had at
madison square guard and after last
night's performance there should be a
jada kiss banner 63 points on dip set
should be hanging forever you know
the rafters along with dick barnett and
walt clyde frazier and dave de busher
bill bradley there should be another
name that's hanging in the rafters
as well that's the great actor richard
schiff because he has been a knick fan
for so long and he has endured the
dumpster fire that is the james dolan
era
of the new york knicks that they should
forever immortalize this man
and hang him in the rafters we are
honored to have him join the show today
thanks so much for taking some time
richard how you feeling where are you in
the world hi
i'm i'm still uh drinking in that
introduction and the idea of
you know whatever my number is being on
the rafter i love it
um i i am can you hear me okay we hear
loud and clear
i am in florida
there is is down in florida golfing i
would imagine something tells you no i'm
i'm not i'm actually down here
getting uh my whole body fixed with
prolotherapy and
prp which is the spinning of the pla
platelets
stuff that remember athletes years ago
used to go to germany because it was
illegal in this country to get their
knees
spun uh uh with prp toby um
that's that's actually what i'm doing
that's embarrassing but i
i have played one round of golf at
benita bay and it was beautiful
although ridiculously hot
i applaud your commitment to the new
york knicks this year richard because
one of the highlights of the season this
year and this season will always hold a
special place
in my heart for many reasons but was
receiving your text messages at all
hours of the nights you're in vancouver
you were watching every single game out
there
isolated in vancouver shooting the good
doctor
staying up late watching the knicks
texting me crazy stuff what was this
season like for you
well first of all uh thank you for being
uh you know a text
partner for uh all of my other nick fan
friends are
long gone were the last ones left
yeah they deserted but um
it was first of all i didn't get every
game because the nba package up in
vancouver
in my neighborhood anyway was such that
they chose what games i could watch
and that pissed me off um so i half of
my texts were coming from what
from game cast on you know the espn
app on the uh on my phone so uh
and i would watch him follow and scream
as you know
the ball bounced around the rim and came
out on a missed shot
um but it was uh it was great
it was you know exciting we had a couple
of spurts
of excitement you know back when um
uh golinari and uh
before the big the big and silly trades
um
when um uh yeah um
you know we have we had a stretch there
what we want 54 games i think one year
and it was exciting
and that disappeared in a flash and so
this year
seeing some a mixture of young kids and
some veterans uh
it was really fun to watch it was where
we're nick fans so we like defense and
it was defense
first kind of uh mentality and i
loved watching it i loved uh uh it was
it was a lot of fun and just
you know to see um our players evolve rj
and
and other guys you know step up into the
next level
uh was great it was a fun fun season we
knew it was going to end
early in the playoffs but it was it was
a blast
richard schiff joins the show right now
die hard nick fan and while i know you
have lots of love in your heart for
the new york knicks i know baseball is
your real thing and the yankees who have
really turned a corner here
brockman our producer a die-hard red sox
fan not having a great back half of the
summer i knew that night in the bronx
when verdugo got
hit in the back with a baseball it was
going to turn the fortunes of both these
teams
were you in the bleachers in yankee
stadium throwing baseballs at alex
verdugo
what happened uh no if it was me it
would be a whiskey bottle
remember the pete rose event back in uh
in 1973 before you were born
no i don't remember that i wasn't born
it was that p pete rose bro
and bud house and got into a fight uh
and pete rose pretty much
you know kicked the living daylights out
of them and the met fans were a little
bit angry the next day
and that's the game that i went to even
though i wasn't a met band
and and fans were hurling uh whiskey
bottles at pete rose and left field
for beaten up little buddy house and the
uh contingency of
old mets including tom sever and a few
member willie mays was back on the team
that year as well in 1973 went out to
out
to the to left field to
to plead with the crowd to please stop
hurling
um uh flying objects at outfielders
with reds uniforms yeah and uh that
reminded me of that when rodrigo got hit
pretty stupid stuff though really stupid
stuff but a moment that i feel like
maybe
galvanized the yankees or got them back
on track because since then they've been
one of the better teams in baseball and
they've
been playing well how how do you put
this yankees team in this season into
perspective and this is why i love
talking sports with you because you
bring up stuff that happened in the 70s
before i was born and you put things in
their proper
context where i get all excited uh tell
me a little bit about your thoughts on
this current yankee team
it's a it's a good thing to bring up you
know the 70s is my favorite
a decade as a yankee fan because i saw
the team that became the 77 and 78 76
they finally want to pin it
after 12 years and i saw the team evolve
you know step by step getting willy
randolph in the trade and
you know when monson rookie of the year
and then get your comes up in 75
76 and so on so um
uh uh this team was uh
we thought was going to be that kind of
team we're seeing the team evolve that
was going to
run a little mini dynasty you know three
a few years ago with
sanchez and judge and um
and the other guys uh and it didn't turn
out that way and
it it's a frustrating so frustrating to
watch this team this year
i know they're playing better but it
doesn't give me a whole lot of faith
because i i just don't get the lack
of small ball it was billy ball that
that made the difference in this in the
70s
you know and in the 90s you had you know
tino martinez led the league with
sacrifice flies
you know where are they where you know
where's the stolen base where's the bunt
you know uh odor bunted the other day
and i
started screaming at the tv it's like
thank you
you know i i you the thing is you can't
build
the yankees are going to parentally
perennially be in it
right we know that this year is going to
be a struggle to get in it but that
probably will do that
then you have to look at the team how
it's how is it going to
function and how is it going to perform
under pressure
against great pitching in a short series
and
are you built to win those tight
one-nothing 2-1 games
um and they're not they're just not
built for that
not only that but the the biggest key in
the 90s
and 2000s was mariano right without
mariano they're not that dynasty
and their and their closing and their
relief right now is is very shaky at
best
although it seems to be putting itself
back into order right
now so i you know it's a very
frustrating
baseball type of baseball to to watch
nowadays
even when they win i like rizzo because
he's a contact guy
they they have more lefties in the
lineup which is you know thank
thanks thankfully finally i don't
understand the way the team was built
uh in the last two years as good as
voigt is and as good as some of the
other right-handed hitters
are you have to have balance you have to
have speed
and you have to have contact hitters and
people are not a bunt to win a short
series
richard schiff joins the show you know
from abc's good doctor
die hard nick and yankees fan what would
ohtani look like in pinstripes
uh very very very nicely
such a baseball fan you must love seeing
what he's been able to do in
in such a short time in the bigs well
he's a
you know a stunning athlete i mean to
have that kind of power and to have that
kind of arm
i you know i you kind of root for a way
in which he won't get
uh broken down and hurt you know like he
has been
um but they're all get they all get hurt
nowadays
um but yeah it's remarkable i'd i don't
get to see
him perform very often because i'm not
in l.a anymore but
uh yeah now it's it's it's
it's special and he has speed you know
yeah and he hits for average
you know all the all all great things
does everything as a player which is
often how you're described as an actor
i've seen you in all types of projects
over the years i was flipping through
the dial the other day jurassic park two
you're the guy who saves them
and then a pterosaur tyrannosaurus rex
shows up and you don't make it to
jurassic park three
and you've popped up in so many things
over the years uh recently ballers of
course which we're interested in on this
show what do you remember from your days
on set with the rock and
some of your first interactions uh he's
just a sweetheart i mean i
wish i had some dirt i could spread it
you know and make this more interesting
but he's a sweetheart uh his works hard
he gets up at three o'clock every
morning works out for two hours
does his business comes to set and has a
full day and and we have fun
we had we had such a blast with rob
cordrey and
later on with stephen weber and as my
brother
and uh just nothing but fun i thoroughly
and totally enjoyed
working on that show and and the rock is
uh is it is just a good a good man
i've got another connection to uh sports
storytelling brockman was surprised to
learn that you pop up in major league
too
yeah that's correct what do you remember
from your time on set from major league
two brockman still doesn't believe you
actually don't believe it
i'm gonna go back and watch it you don't
remember the scene i gotta go back come
on
you gotta go back and watch it man
remember when uh charlie
sheen's character was uh uh doing
commercials
and uh the uh the accoutrements of
success in baseball and i played a
director
of the tv commercial and charlie was
getting everything wrong
and uh i got a little frustrated over
time and uh
uh it's actually a fun scene i i enjoyed
it i remember
just you know meeting charlie and who
i've worked with later on and
of course got to know his entire family
eventually
um and it was just a day job you know
back when i was
you know uh crawling my way up the
ladder
if you will uh but it was a fun it was a
fun day
richard schiff joins the show you know
from abc's the good doctor ben lyons in
for rich on the rich eisen show
if memory serves you first moved to los
angeles right around the time where kirk
gibson hit that home run
uh yeah memory serves you well
what do you remember about being in los
angeles come into la start your career
as an actor
and the dodgers are in the world series
i yeah it goes
a little deeper than that because we my
friend brian and i
at the time we uh
we made our money to cross country
gambling on the mets in 86 in 88
uh if you remember david cohen had a
great year i think it was 23 that year
uh goods were still pitching okay we
rode the mets
gambling and made thousands of dollars
enough to buy a car
and uh and we had just done a movie
together brian and i
uh my first or second movie it was going
to be screened in la
um i had just gotten a divorce and had
bad memories on every street corner in
new york
and he goes hey let's move to l.a and i
went okay
so we removed and um
gambled our way all the way across the
country camping on any game that we
could find on the radio
stopped in vegas where i lost half of it
and then
uh got to l.a and we knew uh
keith miller the utility second baseman
so we got seats to the mets and dodgers
and we of course bet the mets because we
rode them all here
they lost to uh hershey's got hot
so i dropped it all whatever i had left
in my life whatever
cash i had scraped together to to make
my trip out to la
all on oakland in game one
and we we played our first softball game
out at in malibu went to the malibu inn
uh to to watch the game conseco hits the
grand slam
we're up four to three dennis eckersley
who you know hasn't given up a home run
in two years or future hall of famer
um hits i forget who it was i don't
think it was alfredo griffin but
somebody like that
in the knee there's a man on first and
last order
sends excuse the express i called the
[ __ ] but i shouldn't do that
sends up a guy who shouldn't be playing
in the game because he was scratched
almost he was hurt he had only one leg
and uh
accuracy i since talked to eckersley
about this i since talked to kurt gibson
about it
and other major leaguers and i always
ask why
why oh why after he fouled off and
couldn't catch up to ten straight fast
balls did you throw him
a change up or an off seat uh take it
back door slider and throw him
no one can answer that not even equally
and gibson put one hand on it
and it and he's so strong that he hit it
out dodgers won
malibu win went berserk and i was broke
and that's uh my first week in l.a
wow oh my god los angeles story
then you go on and win multiple emmys
and have a great career as an
actor and someone tells me you weren't
betting on baseball games too soon after
that happened the next day
it took a while to get over a while to
recover
uh from that event that was that was the
last bed i've made i haven't made a bet
since that day
richard schiff joins the show last thing
richard what color lakers carmelo
anthony jersey should i buy
what color don't hit me don't entertain
this
richard he's coming to win a
championship we have to root for carmelo
he's our guy richard
once a nick always a nick you're not
rooting for mellow in l.a you're not
bleeding purple and gold
i gotta tell you i don't know how where
you are if we talked about carmelo but
for my money car i'd like carmelo did
just fine in new york
and they didn't surround him with the
right people look he's no different than
uh
the name just popped out of my head
who's our number one guy in new york
right now he's randall r.j barrett
yeah uh the randall right uh and uh
randall's no different he he takes the
ball he's one-on-one
he may he creates he creates for himself
that's what mello did
you know they just and when people when
they called on up to play power forward
and to get rebounds he did that
i i liked mello i just don't like the
team back then
so i yes i'm rooting for him i want his
legacy to turn around
um but i hate the lakers so much it's a
mixed bag i despise them
it's going to be tough site when you see
me pull up on the first tee with a
purple and gold carmelo hat on i think
it's good
so if i ever see you without that knick
hat on the first tee
there's going to be trouble you might
throw some of those clubs you throw at
me
instead of down the fairway there you go
you know accidentally it could happen
richard schiff joins the show we
appreciate you taking some time and
hope we get to tee it up soon my friend
me too pal nice to see uh nice to talk
to you and i miss you i'll see you soon
thank you
love to sheila shouts out to richard
schiff joining the show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here